- [Narrator] This penny
isn't worth 1 cent.
It's worth 10 billion at
least for this video, okay?
And it's going into the Treasury
to be spent on an entire year
of the Environmental Protection Agency.
Here's how much went to
unemployment and NASA.
Last year, more than six
trillion, or 627 pennies,
were spent on different programs,
but that required taking on
more than $1 trillion in debt.
Let's go to the board to
look at federal spending,
including that debt,
and the ways the U.S.
could borrow fewer pennies.
But first, where did all the pennies spent
in 2022 come from?
Here's how many came from revenue.
Things like individual income taxes
and payroll taxes and corporate taxes.
Congress is responsible
for both these totals.
They set the tax rate and
they authorize the spending,
but since these don't match up,
the Treasury takes on debt
to cover this difference.
They do that by selling securities
like say, a 20-year bond.
An investor gives the Treasury money
and the Treasury would
pay interest on that
every six months.
They'll do that until the 20 years is over
and then the investor
will get their money back.
But those interest payments add up.
- That is one of the expenses
that people who worry about
the debt and the deficit
like to focus on the most,
or they see as one of
the biggest problems,
is how much does the US
government pay on an annual basis
just on paying its previous debts?
- [Narrator] In 2022, it was a lot.
8.5% of all spending went to
paying interest on that debt.
- The concern is that
so much money over time
will start going just towards the debt
that you may not be able to spend
what you wanna spend on other issues.
- [Narrator] Here are the other places
the U.S. spent money in 2022.
This biggest section here
is all Social Security.
These sections, Medicare and Medicaid.
This third biggest
section is the military.
Then there's the Department of Education.
Most of this is student loans,
the cost of Biden's potential
student loan forgiveness plan.
There's tax credits like child credits,
Veterans Affairs, and
nutritional services, like SNAP.
The rest of this other
category went to smaller places
like Coronavirus relief, the
Department of Transportation,
or Homeland Security
- Beyond Medicare, Social Security,
interest payments on the
debt, and the Pentagon budget,
everything you think of in terms of
what the federal government
does on an annual basis
is actually a a small minority
of actual annual government spending.
- [Narrator] In 2022, more
than 20% of that spending
was funded by taking on debt.
This is the total amount of
debt built up every year.
It's currently a little over $30 trillion,
and there's a cap to how much this can be.
The infamous-
- Debt ceiling.
- [Narrator] That limit
is currently 31 trillion.
An amount that the Treasury
is set to hit in June.
When that happens, they'll be unable
to take on extra debt
through those securities,
which means there won't be enough cash
to pay Social Security benefits.
Seniors won't get their checks,
neither would members of the military,
and these debt holders wouldn't
get their interest payments.
- That would create all sorts
of financial and economic problems.
Because U.S. treasuries are viewed
as kind of this safe haven asset
for the global financial system,
there's this idea that if
suddenly investors thought,
"Well, if I buy U.S. government debt,
I might not get my money back,"
that there could be a sell
off in U.S. government bonds
and that would raise interest rates
across the world economy.
- [Narrator] It's up to
Congress to pass a bill,
that the president then signs,
to raise this limit so
that doesn't happen.
Both parties agree this
chart should go down,
but they disagree on how to do that.
- If you're trying to reduce the deficit
or eventually even reduce the debt,
it is to either cut
spending or to raise taxes.
- [Narrator] Many Democrats
want to raise taxes
on the rich and corporations.
- I wanna make it clear,
I'm gonna raise some taxes.
Many of you who're billionaires out there,
you're gonna stop paying at 3%.
- [Narrator] While Republicans
largely want to see spending cuts,
and they want those cuts
as a condition for
raising the debt ceiling.
Kevin McCarthy even promised to do it
as part of his deal to become Speaker.
- The responsible debt limit increase
that puts us on a path
towards a healthier economy.
- [Narrator] But Democrats
want just a clean raise
to the debt limit to be
able to pay for the spending
Congress already approved.
- It is something that should
be done without conditions.
We should not be negotiating around it.
- [Narrator] So if there were cuts,
where might they come from?
Cuts to Social Security and Medicare
seem to not be an option.
- Social Security, Medicare
is off the books now, right?
They're not be start. We got unanimity.
- [Narrator] And not all Republicans
support cuts to the military.
- I think there's room for
savings in the military too.
- We've gotta get spending under control
but we are not gonna do it
on the backs of our troops.
- [Narrator] Which only
leaves these departments
and discretionary programs
as places for cuts.
- It's safe to say that marginal cuts,
while you know something
that may be worth
considering in various ways,
and whether it's a wise use
of resources to begin with,
are not necessarily something
that's gonna make a major difference
towards reducing a deficit
or, you know, balancing
the budget, for example.
- [Narrator] While
Democrats and Republicans
may disagree how to do that,
they both agree that the U.S.
can't let the pennies stop.
(upbeat music)